in terms of watching were the main
skills that really helped you the most
or why did you kind of focus on because
what I like about you is that you're not
really abrasive you know you're very
calm and collected and and you know very
like
I don't know you approach things in a
very like Gentle Way in some regards
you're not very like loud and obnoxious
even though you get your master class
really well so how did you kind of
position your skill set of like sales
marketing even like how you present
yourself you have to be able to control
your emotions as a man you know you can
get emotional and loud and there's a
time and place for that like I do get
loud sometimes and I do sometimes in
your car emotional but I do it in a very
precise and tactical way when it's only
necessary
um the common Collective man that you
see today is not the same guy that you
know you would have talked to when I was
25 years old when I was 25 years old my
hair was on fire riding sport bikes at a
thousand miles an hour doing stupid [__]
that you know would have has probably
you know potentially killed other people
right
um I was a Speed Demon I've always been
fast and I've always
um you know for example like on the road
road rage you know this topic that you
hear about today guys like me would have
gotten you know road rage if if the guy
uh you know would have cut me off in his
BMW when I was 22 going to my college
courses you know for example and I think
one of the skills that you have to learn
as you expose yourself to successful
people uh network with these people one
of the things you realize is they don't
get emotional they don't get shouty and
Loud all the time right there's a time
and place for it and controlling your
emotions is an incredibly important
skill that you have to learn when to
deliver certain ideas at a louder volume
with some enunciation like there's
different ways to handle certain things
and again you know that wisdom comes
with time unfortunately so I've had to
put in the time to get that but uh you
know here I am today's you know sitting
before you in that condition
um you have to evolve you know it's
basically what I'm saying like as you as
you grow and you expose yourself to life
and culture and different ideas you have
to learn from them adapt and take what
works for you and add it to your belief
system so that you make better choices
to get those results that you want
um people don't paint very clear
pictures in their lives like if
people that want things
will actually sit down and create a
vivid Vision or a painted picture of the
kind of life that they want
um business coaches do this a lot so I
had a business coach in you know the
2000s 2006 seven eight or and around
those years and one of the concepts that
you know we created for the business was
a painted picture and you paint this
vision for the kind of business that you
want to run the kind of profit margins
you want the kind of awards that you
want to be recognized for the kind of
staff that you have uh how you envision
you know your customers seeing you how
the public sees you know your business
you create this very clear picture and
now that you've got this clear picture
about the kind of Life the kind of
business that you want to run now every
single day when it comes down to making
decisions you know what the end result
looks like you know what Z looks like so
a b through Z can now easily be
constructed because you know how to get
to Z because you know what Z looks like
it's very clear right so if you find
yourself doing things that doesn't lead
to Z then you stop doing them
right a very simple way to sort of put
it is
if you launch a ballistic missile and
you know what the target is
there's wind factor there's the
rotational you know forces of the earth
there's gravity these all these things
that play on the direction that a
ballistic missile will travel but a
ballistic missile is going to be
programmed to hit a certain Target wind
moves it gravity pulls it rotation of
the earth you know does something to
change its trajectory it's constantly
making adjustments
as a man you have to constantly make
adjustments in your life you have to
learn right and then adjust learn adjust
learn adjust and I don't think enough
guys take that seriously you know
they're way too busy wrapped up in their
head guys get wrapped up in their head
about the dumbest [__] ever like oh
um you know my girl is talking to this
guy she has a guy friend that I don't
know what to do and I don't want to seem
controlling or I don't want to you know
try to enforce boundaries because that
would seem like strange or weak or
something like that and it's like no no
absolutely not why are you wasting
energy worried about that [__] when all
you need to do is set a boundary and say
I don't date women that hang out with
their exes that's it she wants to hang
out with her exes see you bye I'll
replace you you know if you're going to
be that kind of gal if that's who you
are that's fine that's cool not a
problem I don't waste energy on things
that are unnecessary but guys consume
themselves with it and they'll stalk
them and they'll look on social media
and they'll see who you know who likes
the the posts in the comments and
they'll click through and see what guys
are like women do this a lot too this is
a very feminine type of behavior but I
see a lot of guys doing this now too
because you know they don't know how to
handle women they don't know how to like
have frame when it comes to a long-term
relationship with women they're very bad
at this sort of stuff so they get
wrapped up in the wrong [__] and it's
like dude no wonder you're poor and fat
you've been spending all your time being
beta ties by this chick who's who you're
completely in her frame she doesn't
respect you she doesn't admire you she
doesn't look up to you no wonder you're
having difficulties in life
that Focus that you've had or been able
to like stay calm is the reason why
you've been so consistent in everything
because you don't lean into like shiny
penny syndrome like fair enough you
might identify the next opportunity but
you don't like [__] off and do something
completely random which I see time and
time again and I'm not like [__] on
younger it's just the fact that like
that's called knee shopping and you
probably might see it on Twitter people
swap from this to this to this to this
to this like for me I spent three years
podcasting my business run that
everything is just one thing right I
don't give a [__] I don't want all this
other all this other stuff and funny you
say this now because one of this kind of
startup that I'm an advisor on or as I
speak to them last week and we're
talking about everything all Focus right
focus focus focus and he was like yeah
but I have this other opportunity that
I'm thinking about doing anything by
starting and I was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa this is the reason why
you you know you chase two hairs you
catching on whatever the [__]
expression is you need to have that
Singularity focused and I I've learned
that the hard way right and I'm not
saying is from a you know up here a
percent perspective I was working 95 I
was trading I was doing a coaching thing
it was all bollocks all waste of time
but when I brought it into one Central
team that's when my life started to
improve and that's where I want that's
where I see the next spread but it's
meant to be boring though right I don't
know I'd like to get your thoughts on
this is that like when you're building
something it's meant to just be you have
to go overnight so you follow like every
single overnight success everybody
that's been labeled as an overnight
success didn't sleep at night sweated
you know bled there was tears there was
heartbreak there was betrayal all of
that stuff along the way is all
dismissed and ignored and invisible
because all they see is
Lambo private jets beaches Dubai girls
bottle service that's what they see and
they don't realize that everything that
led up to that is usually a decade of
sacrifice and hard work but most people
aren't willing to do that they're not
willing to do the boring hard work
they're not willing to do that work
because it's not sexy you know you can't
post a lot of that on social media and
get acknowledgment or get validation for
it it's it's it's all this all these
invisible choices that you make every
single day that lead to the results they
got which look like an overnight success
overnight successes don't exist every
single overnight success is at least a
decade of work usually yeah and what uh
hormones he says in this is that this is
what I heard feels like when it's meant
to be when it's really [__] really bad
that's when you push through and I've
I've experienced that firsthand you know
just it just keep on going and of course
it might not work out but I always think
about it right if it doesn't work out
well it was never going to work out in
your [__] job anyway technically from
the truth is is if you want something
bad enough you'll find a way to make it
happen or you'll find an excuse and most
people find excuses I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out